oh thought it'd be fun to chat about
science big stories of the year I'm
gonna do a a final year-end wrap-up
on my YouTube channel Dr Brian Keating
you guys can join up over there
and I've got a phenomenal episode with
uh Dr Professor Stacy McDonough of Case
Western Reserve University where I went
to school as an undergraduate so 30
years ago who does not believe in the
existence of dark matter
so we had a great conversation about
uh the discontents of dark matter and
physics in general why people are so
married to ideas and get so frustrated
when the prevailing paradigms are
challenged
even as he admits that even his favorite
alternate to dark matter which is called
Monde modified Newtonian Dynamics
um he he also admits that has some
serious flaws in it as well that have to
be
reconciled or answered to and I think
we're kind of at the precipice of
perhaps a breakthrough in physics at
least in maybe the sociology of physics
because
I wonder if we can ever get past the
the precipice of you either you know
agree 100 with my pet Theory or my
interpretation of data or where you know
sworn enemies and there's been a lot of
that been pushed back to mind and even
some from the modern Community pushing
back on
on the prevailing attitude that dark
matter is in the front of a particle
and I'm just interested to see where the
data take us I think it's uh perhaps you
know among the top mysteries in all of
science not just in cosmology or
astrophysics that I studied
and uh because of that I think we're uh
we're due for some real shake-ups and it
may it may be that we have to do away
with the notion of dark matter or we may
have to get used to the
notion that dark matter even if it
exists can't be measured it may only
interact via gravity in which case
there's no hope for
directly detecting it as it would be if
it was say a wimp which is a weakly
interacting massive particle so we know
of only one form of dark matter and it
is a particle it's called the neutrino
and they only interact via gravity and
the weak Force
but the worst fear would be if gravity
was the only force that a particle of
Dark Matter would interact with and then
we'd be in a situation where dark matter
is true but it can never be detected and
it can never really be falsified either
because we simply could never collect
enough of these incredibly low mass
particles which everybody agrees they
would have to be low in mass in order to
have evaded detection already and also
be compatible with our observations
of the structure in the universe dating
back to the cosmic microwave background
that I study all the way up until the
local uh the local Galactic neighborhood
and even our own Milky Ways properties
are seem to be dominated by an unseen
form of matter
or perhaps a variation in the
gravitational field
and so it's a fascinating scenario to be
in and one of the not really
breakthroughs that we had this year but
maybe a personal breakthrough in that I
got to talk to the two leading opponents
of Dark Matter namely
Stacy mcgaugh at Case Western episode
coming on Wednesday
and the founder of Dark Matter uh
alternative of the founder of the mon
paradigm uh Mordecai Milgram who's a
professor in Israel who came up with
this notion that you could have no
ordinary matter complement in terms of
dark matter you could just have ordinary
matter in the universe
and then on the scale of galaxies
themselves the laws of physics would be
modified hence the term modified
Newtonian dynamic
and it would change accelerate
gravitational acceleration ever so
slightly and only on scales vastly
larger than the size of our galaxy or
because of our solar system rather so it
would be impossible to detect locally
and could only be detected
sort of speaking globally by looking at
ensembles collections of galaxies
clusters of galaxies
Etc
and there have been attempts to really
pursue this
but moreover I found that people are
really either in the dark matter camp or
in the mod camp
and there are very few people that
really want to approach the you know
kind of elephant made by committee uh a
situation where you have some mom you
have some dark matter and certainly
Stacy is not in favor of that
um at least that was my impression from
the interview what was nice about the
interview you'll see it on Wednesday
please set your notification bells in my
channel it'll be also on audio as I have
an audio podcast into the impossible but
if you only listen to it you'll miss the
slideshow very very uh visually pleasing
and
informative slideshow that Stacy put
together suitable for Lay audiences all
the way up to graduate students
so he goes through kind of the initial
motivation for alternatives to dark
matter he goes through the Paradigm Dark
Matter Paradigm the history of it I add
in some of my own history and discuss
the features that were actually
discovered here in San Diego I am
by none other than Vera Rubin who's
credited by many as the discoverer of
Dark Matter although she really wasn't
she did discover it but not for the
first time I think that honor in some
people's minds goes back to uh to people
like ort and others back in the early
1900s but certainly Fritz Wiki at
Caltech in the 30s and 40s started to
think about observations and their
compatibility with matter being the only
source of gravity when that at the end
of the day is the biggest concern that
we have that the amount of matter we see
in our galaxy and most every other
Galaxy alone not all of them is
incompatible with the existence of only
baryonic or ordinary matter
and that existence of ordinary matter
challenging the Paradigm of of gravity
on the Newtonian scale calling out for
not a modification of Einstein or even
Weinstein but actually calling out for
modification of Newton's Newtonian
gravity so in a sense this is really
startling
because you know Newton is what gets us
to the Moon Newton he's the one who gets
us to the the nearby stars and it's
fitting I talk about Newton so give me a
reaction if you know why it's fitting to
talk about Newton today
just I don't know give me a thumbs up or
something today
it says it is his birthday that's right
there are two scientists uh that are
um that are actually born today uh that
are quite familiar one has been on the
into the impossible podcast and that is
uh Professor Paul steinhardt
uh Princeton University who is the
Einstein professor of physics and it's
also an iconoclast in that he doesn't
believe in the existence of inflation
he does not believe that inflation took
place and he's claimed very vigorously
on my channel and then discussions we've
had that we need a true alternative to
inflation and the alternative that he's
most fond of is also having a lot of
Discord in the scientific community in
that it cannot be
really ruled out or motivated the same
way that inflation can so the
experiments that I'm doing with the
Simon's Observatory my colleagues at 17
000 feet and I just got back from Chile
I spent a week in Chile
my third trip there
we deployed the platforms on which these
massive telescopes will be sitting for
the next five to ten years the 200
million dollar project when all is said
and done and it's one of its primary
goals is to study the formation of
structure in the universe at the
earliest moments and that could in most
99 percent of cosmologists mind that
structure formation mechanism was laid
down by what are called inflationary
quantum perturbations
in the space-time metric at a time frame
less than 10 to the minus 36 of a second
so the Paradigm that inflation invokes
is that Quant a Quantum field existed
perhaps eternally and then there's a
fluctuation in the region that we would
later call our observable universe
that's seated in it a curvature
perturbation which then led to an over
density of gravitational potential
onto which Dark Matter would then
accumulate
so dark matter and inflation are
intimately connected
and it's thought that we'll have a will
have a a coupling if you will between
the pattern of structure that we see in
the cosmicary background and we'll also
have a an ability to probe the earliest
fluctuation pattern that was ever
produced so the reason that we're all
here on this Christmas day uh relates in
in some strong sense to inflation
according to its proponents what's so
interesting to me is that the same kind
of proponents of uh in cosmology and
kind of preponderance of working
cosmologists seem to believe that the
universe is dominated by a
um by this as I said form of matter
energy which is unseeable using visible
light or ordinary strong or
electromagnetic interactions therefore
it may only interact weekly
and gravitationally or it may only
interact gravitationally
and so I wanted to tie together
you know these different uh Christmas
Day events and there's one I've left out
which is the James Webb Space Telescope
and who can leave a comment in the in
the uh in this comment section or leave
a reaction if you know why the James
Webb Space Telescope belongs in this
Christmas Spectacular as well
I won't belabor the point uh the uh
James Lewis face telescope was launched
a year ago tonight on Christmas Day
and it has also chimed in if you will
not on inflation not on really the
formation of structure but on dark
matter and the Dark Matter Paradigm
itself
so it's fascinating that these three
kind of Christmas intertwined uh figures
or entities such as James Webb Paul
steinhardt and uh and this dark matter
Paradigm uh and inflation which is not
really supported anymore by one of its
founding fathers which is Paul
steinhardt as I mentioned before
Paul's birthday today James Webb was
launched today and uh and Isaac Newton
was born on this day although uh people
don't believe that the Gregorian
calendar as currently instantiated I
believe he was born on the 4th of
January according to our current
calendar it doesn't matter when he was
born it was Christmas so I think he
believed that he was he was born on
Christmas and he was also a very very
devout Christian
uh it's uh not widely appreciated that
of all his accomplishments the one that
he claimed to be his most superlative
accomplishment was that he remained a
virgin
till his dying day like his hero Jesus
Christ
so uh that's pretty interesting I was
born on Christmas day as well so uh I
think it's it's interesting to look at
these different uh different uh through
these different lenses no pun intended
at the year that we just had in science
where we've had significant challenges
to prevailing paradigms and uh and even
calling into question and the most
controversial I had two controversial
events this this year in my YouTube
channel Dr Brian Keating where I'll have
an upcoming video on the foremost from
the foremost kind of opponent Dark
Matter Professor Stacy McDonald Case
Western uh and uh the the relationship
between that and the debate that I had
or kind of exchanged back and forth with
an opponent of The Big Bang Theory
itself uh his name is uh Eric Lerner Mr
Eric Lerner who operates a YouTube
channel of his own called
lppf Fusion I believe if I'm remembering
the uh channel name and he made
headlines of the summer for a claim that
the Big Bang itself did not happen and
where did he get uh this claim from none
other than the Telescope launched a year
ago today on Christmas the James Webb
Space Telescope so Mr Lerner claimed
that the new data on the properties of
uh especially in particular spiral
galaxies at extremely high redshift
meaning at extremely early ages of the
universe
that those galaxies presented a fatal
challenge not just a challenge but a
fatal challenge to cosmology
and partially in part I think it was
almost a click bait type approach and
this is not a stranger he is not a
stranger to this type of of presentation
for he released in the early 90s right
after the Hubble telescope was released
he produced a book called The Big Bang
never happened
and so Mr Lerner and and myself and
Professor Garrett Lewis of um uh of uh
Australia he and I uh had a discussion
which we present the data and findings
from the perspective of professional
cosmologists acknowledging that there
are challenges to
uh aspects of the Big Bang as there
always have been and always will be
and those gaps Lacuna as I always call
them those are not to be or not
unexpected those are to be expected in
any theory of science the theory of
science that science is complete that's
final that somehow science has is is
perfect and there's no uh gaps or
missing information in any Paradigm or
any uh governing Theory within a
scientific field I think is ludicrous
but nevertheless I think it was
instructive to analyze his claims and so
we went through his claims and presented
counter claims which he never responded
to uh maybe he's out there listening now
maybe he's not uh but we we had a lively
debate over the summer
and uh back and forth discussing the
various uh flaws in his mind fatal flaws
to the Big Bang itself so that would
have been the biggest news perhaps maybe
of all time uh not just of the science
year that was 2022. and again I think
it's fascinating that it's intimately
related to the
to the discoveries that the James Webb
Space Telescope has Unleashed uh and
Webb was also responsible for a very
recent controversy that uh I just kind
of by proxy participated in and that was
the uh that was the notion that James
Webb himself was a homophobe and that he
presided over a particularly onerous
difficult disgusting phase of NASA's
history called the in our government
history called the lavender scare back
in the 50s when he was the chief NASA
administrator who would then later go on
to put NASA on track to land astronauts
on the moon in 1969 which we did do and
very successfully uh in large part
because of James Webb himself so there
was a Cadre of astronomers who presented
their case a lot of which is on Twitter
and they presented it on Twitter and in
other media and then just last week a
week ago Monday there was an article on
the front page of the New York Times
about a a good friend of mine hakima
lashayi who is a professional astronomer
a professor and he and I had a
conversation over the summer about James
Webb we also talked about his research
in solver physics and uh as a
professional astronomer but he is the
president of the National Society of
black physicists
and he on his own are you know some kind
of concern that James Webb Space
Telescope the most expensive project
ever launched into space
would bear the name of a of a homophobe
and he was outraged but he's a black uh
African-American he's a black man and he
was outraged if that were true just as
he'd be outraged if there was a named
after you know the David Duke space
telescopers or something like that and
so he took it upon himself to do a very
deep investigation of James Webb the
history and politics of NASA and
investigate whether or not James Webb
was a homophone and he came up the
answer was negative no James Webb was
not a homophobe according to Hakeem
Professor Hakeem alishay and then what
happened was kind of remarkable there
were a lot of lgbtq and their allies on
Twitter
and even in the pages of Scientific
American who launched a campaign to
discredit not only O'Shea himself uh but
the the findings that he had come up
with namely that James Webb was indeed a
homophobe so the article on the front
page of the New York Times was actually
an investigation into the controversy
itself and what happened to uh my friend
Hakeem and it comes up really not only
exonerating uh Hakeem from any
wrongdoing and character assassination
attempts perhaps or uh and and you know
that maybe that wasn't the intention of
the folks who were writing about it but
that's the way it was perceived and
presented in this article
uh by Michael Powell uh who is uh often
on Twitter as well in the New York Times
last last Monday so it's pretty
fascinating all these things have this
Christmas conversions and here I'm a Geo
okay so I've just made some Chinese food
and I'm you know settling in for the
night uh the last night of Hanukkah
happy Hanukkah to those of you who
celebrate out there uh but nevertheless
a lot of things do seem to happen on
Christmas and uh related to Christmas
and uh and if you've read my first book
losing the Nobel Prize you'll know I was
actually a Jewish altar boy in the
Catholic church back in my teenage years
I'm not going to get into that there if
you're interested I have a video about
that and I have a uh and I have a uh
large chapter in my book about how I
have come back and forth between
different religious practices and I have
a great affection for Catholicism still
but the uh Confluence of these things
and the kind of Hope of looking forward
to the future
uh I think I do so with trepidation for
2023 in that this year's uh has really
shown me this incident that I just
described with my very good friend
imagine you're a good friend
and he
um he or she is assailed online for
doing something that he or she thought
was just doing a good deed investigating
you know the characteristics in the
background of somebody maybe with the
Hope originally of of taking this person
down and and not being associated and
then he finds to the contrary a great
courage a great risk and threats against
him and his career and other things and
uh and then the scientific Community a
large part acts as a mob and tries to
attack not only his findings and his
scholarship but his character making all
sorts of accusations you can read about
those in the article from The New York
Times last week
so that's kind of scary and that kind of
was capped off uh another event that
happened in the home of Catholicism
and by the man who died the year that
Isaac Newton was born and that's Galileo
Galilei died in 1642 which is the year
Isaac Newton was born on Christmas Day
and Galileo ended his life in prison
because of an injunction by the Catholic
Church to never teach the true theory of
copernican or uh the copernican
arrangement of our solar system namely
that the sun is the center of our solar
system not the Earth as as the
interpretation had kind of posited from
the Bible
um I go through in some detail in in
other works that I've gone through that
there's no real evidence at least in the
Torah in the Jewish Bible in the Old
Testament that seems to suggest that the
sun is uh is is not you know the center
of the solar system but nevertheless
there's not much science or cosmology in
the Torah at all but I just found it
interesting that the actual support that
the sun is not the center of the
universe comes from Aristotle who
maintained in Ptolemy who maintained
that the Earth was the center of the
solar system for purely physical reasons
but uh and they weren't Christians
certainly they lived 275 years before
Christ so it always puzzled me why did
the Catholic Church
punish and jail imprisoning
Galileo for teaching that the pagans who
lived in Greece and uh and and Egypt in
the you know pre first Millennium that
they were wrong right why did the church
care if a pagan was wrong I know if if
uh if nowadays if we say some Pagan is
wrong I don't think you know Pope
Francis will will sentence you to you
know in life imprisonment which is what
happened to Galileo and I traveled to
his hometown and I did some research and
did find out more about that event and
found to my surprise uh maybe maybe some
in the audience know this but but that
Galileo
um was really doing battle against a
Christian Saint in that eventually the
Catholic church and the pope thanks to
some of the work of Saint Thomas Aquinas
basically canonize Aristotle as a saint
and so they kind of not only
posthumously made him a Christian they
made him a saint and therefore anything
violating his teachings was literally
sacrilegious
and so in Galileo's defense of
opposition presented first by Copernicus
of the earth-centered universe Leo was
transgressing against
a powerful powerful figure in
Christendom and I found that out this
year and Galileo's actual prison where I
spent some time with Eric Weinstein who
was on a couple minutes ago maybe he'll
come back and uh and then Jay
battacharya Dr Professor Jay
bhattacharya of Stanford University
and he and I became friends over the
summer and that also illuminated a
shameful
event in the history of Science in the
past year which was that he was
basically
um censored and under the same type of
injunction Inquisition
not by the Catholic church anymore but
by uh by Francis Collins of the National
Institutes of Health and by of course
Anthony fauci and that those two
conspired with others including
eventually Rachel Lewinsky who is the
director of the CDC uh to do what was
described by a public takedown of Dr
bhattacharya that his findings and his
recommendations which would later be
termed the Great Barrington declaration
that those were Fringe those were coming
from a fringe epidemiologist so they
they called them that and they called
for in their words a takedown of him and
his cohorts which included the uh a very
eminent bubble Laureate Michael Levitt
as well so it was a number Laureate in
chemistry and they they rude that fact
they were they were upset at that fact
that they had gotten the support of a
Nobel Prize winner as if that was sort
of you know a bridge too far and that
might have pushed them over the edge so
this all happened this year and I think
it was uh it was quite it was quite a
shock to me that scientific authorities
that I you know naively would respect as
a great scientist fauci was a renowned
uh you know medical doctor and textbook
author
Francis Collins of course played the
largest role of any individual at least
in the government funding of the
national of the Human Genome Project
and you can see video of him and fauci
and others and the interview I did with
Jade about acharya about two weeks ago
now it's published on my channel
so I kind of have become a little bit uh
disillusioned at least in the past year
and I'm worried that the next year won't
be much better
um it may be that people uh fear science
because we Revere science we think of
science as as this incredible uh tool
which is true to Gathering and Garner
knowledge
but we don't and produce technology but
we don't look at the fact that science
is done by scientists
and these scientists often have highly
politicized agendas agendas that don't
actually comport with a scientific
worldview
and are fundamentally I think in
opposition to the great dictum of uh
Richard Feynman who said that science is
really the belief in the ignorance of
experts and that if you settled as a
young patent clerk in 1905 for what
Isaac Newton had done again celebrating
his birthday happy birthday Isaac Newton
born on this day in 1642.
if we had settled for Isaac Newton a
young Swiss German patent clerk named
Einstein would have said well he's an
expert and um not as great an expert as
he is and I will just take his word for
it and we would have been stuck with
Newtonian gravity forever
and not not even to mention this this
new controversy which I think is healthy
by the way I want to make a distinction
between healthy controversies healthy
debate like that that's going on and the
debate between dark matter and the
opponents of dark matter that call
themselves modified Newtonian Dynamics
or Bond we'll have a video about that on
Wednesday and my channel Dr Brian
Keating
uh that's healthy to have those debates
as long as it's not ad hominem and
personal and so forth so
um but it's it's kind of
um
and there's more as a byproduct of the
social media age we now have more kind
of suggestions or claims of things like
the big bang never happened and
um and other claims that can't be
substantiated
yet they piggyback on the on the
skepticism that even scientists such as
myself will have and so I'm kind of you
know just just using this as a as a
therapeutic tool to vent to those of you
who are listening that even for
professional scientists it's hard to
know what to do because on the one hand
you want to encourage debate on the
other hand people's minds are rarely
Changed by debate
uh and uh and yet you want to strive for
the focus to be on the flaws in the
current understanding of science without
having those flaws be uh those that that
sort of look for the as as Jesus Christ
said and the uh you know the log and in
your own eye while you're looking for
the speck of dust in your enemy's eye in
other words how can we look a scientist
and be self-critical when we might be
attacked for example Eric Lerner when he
was attacking the uh big bang Paradigm
which is fine and you can certainly
question whether or not the big bang
took place
but in so doing he was claiming that he
was heir to this tradition of Galileo
and Giordano Bruno who was burned at the
stake in 1600 for heretical views about
multiple planets uh in the universe
which of course is true but he didn't
have any evidence for that nevertheless
to claim that you are at the same level
or that you are suffering the same kinds
of of scientific censorship as he called
it is really a colony against the
process of science and even to talk
about things like peer review as as some
sort of corrupt Cobble of cabal of of
disingenuous science grifters you know
to to really go through this
um community of people that are trying
to do their best and understand things
so you have that on the one hand people
attacking science using the well-known
flaws not only in science but in
scientists then you have eminent
scientists attacking other scientists
like fauci and Collins attacking Jay
bhattacharya
and it's quite frankly it's it's it's a
very difficult uh situation to navigate
and I haven't really understood a way to
do that in the best possible way I I do
like the notion at least of having a
debate
um and I've had on uh folks like uh
Peter bagozian who wrote a book called
How to have impossible conversations uh
and yet I don't find that people's minds
are ever changed and it's it's possible
to have your own opinions and science
but as it said it's you can't have your
own you know private fact
and there should be sort of a a a
possibility of a debate but it's almost
impossible because of the academic
hierarchy what I sometimes call the
academic uh the academic industry you
know complex where we have things like
the media that are not in um a direct
conspiracy but they're in a symbiotic
relationship with Scientists in that
you'll get a news story like I'll cover
this hopefully with one of the
progenitors of the experiment uh the
recent announcement of a wormhole
created and using quantum computers like
Google sycamore's computer I hope to
have on Professor Maria
espiropolu at Caltech who is the leader
of This research and um you know she and
I have been talking hope to have her on
uh and you have sort of this immediate
tidal wave of hype that just washes over
not only the scientific literature but
I should say in the Popular Science
literature before it's even had a chance
to truly be digested by other scientists
so at least in that case she published
her paper in nature and that was
released and then it was kind of
Amplified by a friend of mine Natalie
walkover he's a great journalist on the
Pulitzer Prize this year for journalism
and uh he wrote an article and and it
was you know very very glowing and and I
find
um those things very exciting obviously
I was caught up in it and and very
excited about it and I want to bring it
to the attention of my audience and have
a live chat as I do almost weekly with
the world's greatest scientist and
sometimes I tag along too but having
having those kinds of debate now what if
I would have on somebody who is who is
kind of very condemnatory and saying
look this is total hype you didn't
discover what you're claiming you know
it's an approximation you know it's a
simulation you shouldn't have let the
the media run with this in the way that
they have because once you ring the bell
you know once you use the toothbrush you
can't bring it back you can't take it
back to the store and I don't know the
best way to handle that I don't think
it'll be great for my channel I mean let
me know in the reactions if you think
it's a good idea have on you know say
someone who comes up with some great
result like the nuclear fusion result we
heard about two weeks ago now and then
and then have on a vocal critic of that
uh like I did this week with professor
Charles seif of New York University
who's not a physicist but he's a
journalist and he has written his
journalism professor and he has a
science background but he's not a
working scientist but nevertheless he's
been writing about books about fusion
and and it's discontents for over a
decade now
so you know is it a good idea to have on
you know
bitter enemies I don't think that really
teaches the audience of lay people at
least how a good lesson because we don't
really do science like this anymore we
also don't really do science by peer
review except for the fact that there's
really no other way to do it I mean we
can't do like a demonstration as they
used to do at the Royal Society where
Isaac Newton would stand up with a prism
and they would let a beam of sunlight
into the Royal Academy and then he'd
demonstrate what was called color theory
which is very brilliant by the way he
would take sunlight which is yellow but
it has all the colors of the rainbow and
that's why you see all the colors of the
rainbow and there's a moisture in the
atmosphere and then he would diffract it
and then he would have another prism set
up some distance away and in between the
two prison line he would blank out one
of the colors say yellow from the first
Spectrum diffuses the white light or the
yellow white light into to a rainbow and
then it kind of goes across the room a
little bit and then he focuses it and
then he would block out just just oh
make opaque the yellow portion of the
spectrum and then he would recombine the
light with another prism and he would
show you don't get white light out you
get white minus red so or my white one
is yellow so it was a little bit
greenish you know bluish with some some
excess red and it was fascinating to
show the unification of physics of light
of theory and they would actually do
that in person and then and only then
when you could actually demonstrate that
you got a result would you have it be
sort of accepted as a fact and then
you'd publish it in a book and he did
that in the book called Optics it's
spelled with a K which is kind of funny
uh and they would do all this stuff but
you know peer review hasn't been around
for that long uh and you know as I said
recently it's the best system it's the
worst system except for all the others
uh and so going into 2023 we have not
only assault on you know scientific
theories like the big bang
like dark matter Paradigm like uh the uh
the notion of how a particular virus was
created or escaped or you know was
transmitted early on can't believe it
was exactly three years ago I heard
about this virus and I wasn't too
concerned about it and then the whole
world basically shut down for the last
three years we've been dealing with this
including in science including the
shutdown of travel to my Observatory for
the better part of three years uh just
resumed when I was there uh three weeks
ago down in Chile at 17 000 feet you can
find a video about that on my channel
and uh and we have this controversy
within science where you can't even
defend the name of a telescope uh it's
it's it's so hot button it's so it's
such a uh an affront to the community
calling it you know victimization and
and violence to have a telescope named
after someone who is essentially
disproven to be a homophobe or at least
in the context of the Milian which he
was living where the whole federal
government could not uh employ
homosexuals so it wasn't just oh NASA
this one bigot and you know and he had a
chance he could just overthrow NASA and
hire homosexuals left and right uh that
wasn't even conceivable you know it
would be like you know someone hiring a
foreign you know
um a terrorist or something I don't I'm
not equating anything like that but I'm
just saying from a foreign military say
uh let's just hire you know the azov
Battalion into the CIA you just can't do
do such things they're you know even if
even if that was somehow righteous and
and he had a reason to do it it was
impossible for him to do it
um moreover there was actually evidence
that he was supportive of um one lesbian
that he knew at that time which was
extreme publicly supportive not just you
know he was friends with lesbian and oh
some of my friends are lesbian he was
actually supportive and and uh promoted
her research as well so I think uh and
yet my friend Professor Hakeem alishay
was assailed in the science community
and to the point that even the uh one of
the largest journals in all of astronomy
and all of science really monthly
notices of the Royal Astronomical
Society where I published several papers
uh they apparently will not allow you to
use the actual name of the telescope in
an article about data from the telescope
in other words if you measure that the
Big Bang definitely happened
uh just kidding but you measure
something about some Galaxy and you get
it from James Webb Space Telescope data
you are not to say that it won't be
published it would be like you use a
slur according to the editors of that
journal so the editorial practice is not
to publish it
uh there's some similar support and so
you have to use the initials jwst
and uh there's similar uh actions that
were taken by the American Astronomical
Society not who published the
astrophysical journal which is arguably
the biggest pure astronomy journal in
all of Science and that is uh that is
also uh they have taken issue and they
have come out very strong statements
about web based on uh they're concluding
uh similarly to the to the authors of
the piece that condemned uh Professor
olashay so it's very kind of complex but
if you if you check out my YouTube
channel and have an interview with
Hakeem
and I tweeted about it and then followed
Michael Powell uh it's the New York
Times author who published the article
that came out last week on Monday on the
front page so uh those were kind of the
big controversies all in some way
related to Christmas
and I thought it'd be fun to uh to just
share these kind of musings as I eat my
chow mein as a good Jew does
um Christmas night when all is quiet not
even uh I think Nick is around here uh
but I guess uh it's deregura to maybe
see if anybody has any comments or
questions or things they're looking
forward to inside or outside of science
um make a request I'll I can put you on
on the stage as they say this is my
first Twitter space I think this year I
don't know I might have tried one last
year I'm obviously not that great at it
but um if anybody would like to say
anything I will welcome that otherwise I
will get back to my hot and sour soup
and my spring rolls and uh and start
packing we're going to get a big
snowstorm here in San Diego so I am
going to go uh skiing this week with my
family
and uh and I gotta pack up pack up my
stuff uh phony couchy you're up my
friend how are you sir how are you
enjoying your meteorite
you're muted phony oh hi hi thanks for
thanks for giving me the mic and uh yeah
first of all well thank you for sending
me a meteorite in the mail I totally
wasn't expecting that on Christmas Day
um so yeah I mean you bring up a really
interesting topic right like I I've I've
I've been following the whole James Webb
homophobia issue and you know I've I
think my I mean I I think
my my take on it is that I mean he was
probably
you know like basically who was working
within the constraints of his time but I
think like the thing that we get
sidetracked with is a lot of uh people
are
really interested in fighting culture
Awards without necessarily focusing
their attention on
um improving the conditions of the
people who they're fighting
sort of culturally for you know like how
are you actually trying to make the
lives of people who are lgbtq better I
rather than you were just wasting your
time
on this meaningless name thing like it's
already happened okay I don't know I
don't think it's meaningless I don't
think it's meaningless to I mean imagine
if there was you know the Adolf Hitler
space health and I I would be against
I'm going to the extreme for this and
they weren't claiming that at that level
but they were doing something more
pernicious in my opinion yeah it's just
a smear not only to smear the name of of
the telescope but to smear the black man
Hakeem olashei professor of astronomy uh
for doing the research almost as if you
know and and actually some of the some
of the controversy surrounds the fact
that he's black in other words Black
Folk aren't supposed to come to the
defense of white racist homophobes uh
and that was some of the claims I mean
I'm not making this as Professor Chando
uh Prescott Weinstein who is a friend
and and I've hosted her and and she's
she and I you know are fresh she's she's
got you know she's uh she's she's you
know an esteemed colleague in the field
of physics but she was essentially
calling Hakeem and Professor James Gates
member of the National Academy of
Science he won the National Science
medal uh that basically because of their
race
which I don't understand what that has
to do with uh homophobia from James Webb
when the whole federal government was
you know ensconced in it back in the
1950s so I take more issue with that how
can a scientist and others how can a
scientist you know kind of who is
logical who is rigorous who is rational
how can they claim such things uh it was
it's very demoralizing to me as a
scientist and like I said I don't know
how do you separate the the fear that I
have for science that you you have only
a few limited tools to grasp the
universe and then you have people that
are your fellow Travelers and then
they're using those very tools against
you uh in the case of the Big Bang never
happened in the case of uh people that
are opposed to theories such as
inflation uh the the vitriol that they
get not from the general public only but
from scientists it's very it's
demoralizing at some level and I don't
know how to teach my students what to do
because you know we hear about this this
notion of allyship and you should be an
ally but what does that mean I mean
should you because I'm Jewish that I
just reactionably just support chonda
Prescott Weinstein because she's Jewish
or because she's black Hakeem should
have supported her I just don't know
what to do
um so let's see I'm gonna invite Erica
he always has something interesting oh
sorry yeah go ahead foni yeah sorry I
mean before I go I wanted to
um put this one question for you uh I
don't know if you've seen there was this
paper that came out that was questioning
the results of the ehtc m87 black hole
image that was by a Japanese group and
it was published in the astrophysical
journal and they said he said that the
image that the ehtc group came up with
that was uh with the result of an
artifact of the field of view uh yeah I
was kind of like surprised that most
science communicators sort of shunned
away from this topic
and uh so I thought that that would be
kind of uh
uh insightful to see what your take on
this is yeah okay thanks Tony and you
know I'm sorry that you called my good
friend Jay bhattacharya a French
epidemiologist please don't do that
again
I won't send you another meteorite phony
um okay I'll get back to that
controversy but I I do want to have uh
Eric opine about this uh controversy
that we had in science this year several
things Eric just to recapitulate really
quickly we had situations where eminent
scientists were using their privilege
and Prestige as scientists to both
attack legitimate scientists like Jay
bhattacharya and uh condemning him
essentially with the help of
organizations and entities outside of
the scientific establishment namely
Twitter and and uh perhaps other
entities suppressing uh information
that's purely scientific
as you know and also the extra
scientific you know basic character
assassination attempts at people who are
trying to Simply engage and correct the
historical record wherever it may lead
so if you have any opinions Eric it
would be interesting to hear them
and you want to do this on Christmas
well it's Christmas Eric because a
couple of things James Webb was launched
a year ago today on Christmas time
uh Jay battacharya and I met in a place
called archetri Italy on at the place
where as you know because you were there
uh that Galileo was imprisoned for
heresy by the Catholic Church Galileo
died in 1642 the very year that Isaac
Newton was born on Christmas Day and
last but not least the attacks on
opponents of inflation and I didn't
bring this up yet but the Multiverse and
the so-called string landscape LED by
Paul steinhardt Professor Einstein
professor of physical sciences at
Princeton also born on this day in 1952.
so there's a Confluence of Christmas
related activity so that's why we're
bringing it up today
wonderful well Merry Christmas Dr
Keating uh happy Hanukkah happy Hanukkah
as well uh I guess what my take is is
that we've got to
um how to put this politely
it's too cheap to create controversies
which force everyone to have opinions in
areas that we really
uh
I don't know what the evidentiary
case is for the the idea that James Webb
was a raging homophobe at Nasa it
doesn't seem a very compelling story and
my feeling is is that if something
doesn't meet this threshold
let's say
um it shouldn't be the case that
individual members of the community
uh simply by making a frivolous attempt
uh to enmesh us once again in
relitigating the past
I don't think that we should all get
taken off the line and be forced to
debate what somebody decided was
important for us to debate and in the
case of uh
this is preposterous you know you're now
in a situation where you have the uh the
FBI saying who are you gonna believe me
or Your Lying Eyes
um with respect to the Twitter files and
we now have fauci and Colin's emails
talking about the need for a Swift and
devastating takedowns of the Great
Barrington
um declaration as well as uh you know
this this desire to reframe Oxford
Stanford and Harvard as employing French
epidemiologists uh
there there's this concept of race
ipsiloquital in the law that I'm quite
partial to which is where things speaks
for itself this is now so dumb
that uh we should be having a blast I
don't think we should be like worried
about Jay bodachari we should be making
fun of Tony fauci and Francis Collins
because they're Preposterous but when
you do that Eric I I I I I just started
with uh with respect when you do that
say with Professor Prescott Weinstein no
relation as I understand it uh when you
do that you can then be accused of not
being an ally you can then be accused of
homophobia by proxy you can then be
accused of not being skin folk aren't
Kinfolk to use her her words and
um and so where and she's a scientist so
where can you draw the line and and not
be and meshed in the con and just do the
science are you advocating you know I
should just keep my head down and just
do the science or that I should
devastatingly take take down Chanda
Prescott Weinstein which I have noticed
wait wait wait a second I I'm not even
focused on on the names in this case oh
fine fine well you said fauci but well
no because fauci is representing an
institution and Collins I mean in NIH
Nia I ID and National Institute for
allergies and infectious disease and and
uh NIH are enormous
institutions I'm not aware
of uh Dr Prescott Weinstein Heading an
enormous institution so I don't feel
that we should be giving them uh all the
same trees well I I did mention sorry
Eric just because you dropped off for a
second I did mention that the monthly
notices of the Royal Astronomical
Society which has a impact factor you
know maybe third on the tops for fellow
astronomers they will not print the name
James Webb Space Telescope you can only
refer to it okay that is an inspiration
right right I understand that this is
all very dangerous stuff right it's
going to derange society what I'm trying
to say is
we've now been through what five years
of complete Insanity and including you
can't use the word insane at Stanford uh
yeah
at some point
uh you have to I think I'm done with
12th chances is what I'm trying to say
um and giving everyone the time well
what do we think what do we you know
okay well the whole point is that's
paralytic
and it wastes our research time and it
wastes our Focus so instead of talking
about
anisotropies in The Cosmic microwave
background radiation uh or you know
looking at at Star nurseries or
something like that we're having one
more discussion about allyship and
homophobia so let me just put forward a
really a kind of a clearer idea I think
allyship should die
and I think it it's because it
diminishes friendship it diminishes
collegiality it's some sort of very weak
form of support where one party agrees
to sort of lie
um
prostrate before another thing I I'm so
sorry that we've wronged you uh how can
I simply support you in whatever it is
that you do and it's like well that's
not going to be friendship and that's
you're not going to have children that
way if we're really serious about
multiculturalism and getting rid of
racism let's effing love each other and
let's work together and let's tell our
black colleagues when they're completely
out of their minds just as black
colleagues should tell white colleagues
when they're completely out of their
minds but this idea of creating a sort
of uh
intersectional
um I don't know kind of uh hierarchy
where the most intersectional person is
the only person who can comment on
things is bananas and we all know that
what I'm trying to get at is I think
it's time to lower the courtesy level to
unworkably bad ideas like allyship it
doesn't work friendship Works love works
collegiality works Merit Works let's use
those and let's give allyship I don't
know the next few decades off uh let it
figure out what it wants to be and then
it can come back and it can help us to
investigate neutrino physics
um or x-ray telescopes or or what have
you but it doesn't seem to work and I
don't see taking all of civilization
uh that has been shown to work in the
past and passing it through a filter
that appears to destroy all adult subtle
and uh and kind of adventurous thought
um in this completely untrust
untrustworthy Shredder machine for the
human intellect I just think it's a bad
idea no I agree and I was saying also
Eric you know that there's a the media
play a huge role in it and it's not just
Twitter amplifying certain voices in the
scientific Community as if they have a
Phalanx uh PhD epidemiologist and
astrophysicist on there on there what uh
Cuttery but I wonder what do you do when
there's when there's scientific
criticism like this summer I was saying
I engaged in a controversy of whether or
not the big bang even happened based on
a claim by an individual who who says
based on James Webb's face telescope day
again James Webb has launched a year ago
today on Christmas that's why it's
relevant to the space uh no pun intended
the claim was that because the property
of galaxies that we shouldn't take the
Big Bang claim anymore as being
legitimate in other words my bread being
buttered by the big bang and this is
what I get accused of by the way that
I'm in the pocket of big cosmology or
how do I separate as a scientist and
you're a scientist uh mathematical
physicist too how do we separate
legitimate gripes against claims
including claims by this individual Eric
Lerner who claims that he's being
censored like geodona Bruno and gal and
I always say by the way if you ever
compare yourself to Giordano Bruno your
career's all over but not because you're
being censored but because you're a
numbskull so but anyway
um is there censorship is Clinton peer
review you know that the editors won't
even look at his paper uh meanwhile this
is the same paper he tried to publish 30
years ago when the Hubble data were new
uh it's basically the same type of
argument that the properties of spiral
galaxies are to mature and develop to
have done so in 400 million years which
is a legitimate claim you can claim it
but there's no evidence except now that
he says well Bruno was censored Galileo
was censored and uh and now I'm being
censored too and therefore I am like
them how do you handle that as a
scientist what would I tell my questions
so first of all you you look at Short
interest
uh in general we should be able to
profit from shorting people
who are completely wrong
um you should be able to go short in the
marketplace of ideas the concept of a
complete Market is one in which you can
find an investment instrument for any
thesis that you might have so if you
have an idea about the world and you see
that the world has not caught up with
you you should be able to bet it and
profit so I would be very curious if we
opened an idea Market what is the short
interest in this because quite honestly
I would love to make some money
um
I think it's also really interesting
when you have
far out their ideas that turn out to be
right like you know famously that stress
doesn't cause ulcers
um in fact pathogens cause ulcers
so you have to be very careful about
saying that somebody's just completely
wrong but you should be able to gauge
you see you can't really go by the
community because very often one person
is right and everybody's wrong that's
what makes some of the most exciting
science exciting on the other hand you
can't afford to let any lunatic
um
just say something and then have that
well you know the the
Court of public opinion is um is evenly
divided that's not true either so we
have to get away from the idea that peer
review works because we've shown that it
doesn't we have to get away from the
idea that you can test everything in
experiment obviously you can't run the
Big Bang uh over and over again to get a
high enough n science is a lot more
interesting and complicated and complex
than most of the attempts to turn it
into a simple thing where you know if
something doesn't match experiment then
it's wrong like you know you can find
Feynman saying this I think at Cornell
and he's just he's incorrect
uh science is a really complicated
Endeavor and in part we don't know
whether our lunatics are correct
sometimes and that's what makes it uh
really interesting is that we should be
allowing this person to put their iron
in the fire
and we should watch it and we should
make very sure that if the community
picks this up later
that the Heretics are lifted up because
one of the problems that I have is that
the Heretics often don't benefit when
the community finally gets around to
something and realizing that there were
Heretics talking about it it is all too
frequent that the people who are the
Johnny come lately get all of the credit
so I think we have a really interesting
thing but let me just say something
Brian that I would really rather have I
would love to hear Brian Keating
talking not about the culture wars and
not about some crazy idea about the Big
Bang never happened but I'd love to hear
you talking about what you're excited
about
um with respect to let's say CMB
radiation and what you're looking for
and what's going on in the Simon's
telescope and what I think we should get
away from is the fact that there's a
quick hit you get whenever you get
controversy but we lose out on the Great
Adventure of science which is often very
slow moving so I'm going to demote
myself to the audience because I have to
get back to some stuff but I wanted to
just say merry Christmas happy Hanukkah
I think we should we should learn to
just
silence our our own desire to be good
long enough to investigate whether or
not we need to be plunged into yet one
more irrelevant controversy which
detracts from the science and tends to
build Envy through invidious Behavior
between the communities I think we need
to get back to loving the [ __ ] out of
each other being collegial with each
other and realizing that we're all in
this for the science or it doesn't make
any difference I don't think we need to
have a question about whether Orion
identifies as female and that the
constellation should be changed in the
skies it's just a waste of everyone's
time thanks so much thank you Eric happy
Hanukkah and a merry Christmas happy New
Year yeah I too have to leave and finish
my chow mein in a few minutes but we did
have a chance to chat a little bit about
the exciting developments at least in
the alternatives to the Paradigm of of
uh what's called cold dark matter that
has pervaded cosmology since its first
initiation by Fritz Wiki it was a you
know kind of a a un a little bit of an
anxious character at Caltech not too
long ago uh and there's still a great
controversy about that and so the thing
that's most exciting me as Eric
mentioned is is R should say are the
cracks are the flaws as uh I think it
was uh Cohen who said you know the
cracks are where the light gets in how
does the light get in you know know
you're on to something in science if you
find something that's flawed saying and
you know that it's mostly say The Big
Bang Theory is mostly correct but it is
only a scientific theory and it's only
made by scientists therefore there's
profit to be had in Eric's language uh
from going long as well as shorting
perhaps individuals but going long uh
the notion that you will find the most
curious the most fascinating and the
most impactful research directions when
you look for things that shouldn't be
there not for the thing that you
expected to be there as uh Feynman said
that very same quote that Eric was
mentioning that you are the easiest
person to fool and the first principle
in science is not to fool yourself so
don't fool yourself I think is good
advice for this coming year and the
things that I'm most looking forward to
or the Simon's Observatory collecting
its first Cosmic photons from the site
that I just visited and I have a little
tour of that site on my website sorry on
my YouTube channel Dr Brian Keating
and that uh site I show you around what
we're doing up there and it's uh gotten
to be basically the world's highest
operating astronomical Observatory and
we'll be taking data for the next decade
or so aiming to uncover what was the
universe like in its first few moments
when it came into existence whether
there was a universe that preceded our
universe whether it be due to a collapse
in a preceding Universe a big crunch
maybe an infinite cycle of universes and
what's called a cyclic cosmological
model whether or not we live in a
Multiverse perhaps of infinite companion
universes these are the features which
the Simon's Observatory which I co-lead
with my colleagues at Princeton and Penn
UC Berkeley in Chicago and what we can
do with that magnificent instrument will
first come into view next year in 2023.
I'm incredibly excited about that as I
may be a little bit dismayed by some of
my colleagues and what they're doing in
the field so stay tuned this is coming
this coming Wednesday I have an
interview with Stacy McGaw who's a
professor at Case Western Reserve
University one of the foremost opponents
of dark matter and so he and Mordecai
Milgram who is on the show this summer
uh discuss the alternative called the
mod or modified Newtonian Dynamics which
would change our interpretation of the
most dominant form of matter that there
is in the universe from existing to
non-existent and that would be a
revolution in modern cosmology and it
might be concomitant with our
understanding of how galaxies got their
spin on and so that will tie into the
James Webb findings and uh we will be
uncovering the properties of the
Universe on its largest possible skills
so I want to encourage you all yes
please do subscribe and be like phony
couchy not like Tony fauci but be like
phony touchy who's who's up on stage for
a brief moment uh if you subscribe to my
newsletter there's a good chance you
will win a piece of space Schmutz some
Cosmic dust some debris from an exploded
Supernova that existed in our galaxy
uh about four billion 500 million years
ago and I send those out and Tony
received one phony received one uh just
today so just in time for Christmas and
I'm also giving away copies of my
audiobook done with Frank wilcheck Jim
Gates Carlo ravelli and others which is
Galileo's only existing audiobook called
the dialogue on two World Systems find
that on my website Brian keating.com
list and YouTube may win and then tune
in on Wednesday and I'm hoping to have
Dr Weinstein on the show for one last
swan song for 2022 we review the
greatest hits and misses and our time
together in Italy which is not to be
missed so for now wishing you all happy
Hanukkah to those that celebrate merry
Christmas happy New Year joyous Kwanzaa
all the other things that you may
celebrate I can't wait to go further
into the impossible with all y'all in
2023 thanks everybody take care
thank you Dr King